oh you seen it quit me you see let your
fifty it'll be due to act like you're a
beer and I'm gonna pretend I'm dead you
shot a man fifty you need a baby want to
get why I was gonna want to do a sketch
of Instagram sketch of Brennan he's like
will that wait till I warm up you get a
warm oh I just got here
you didn't warm up and I said you're 50
and you wanna pretend I'm a beer
well you'd play dead I'm positive funds
gets funny so I didn't want to do it I
got and then what ruin it is before you
told a horrible story that you'd have to
be in person to understand yeah so our
semaa chan and i literally I don't know
what I'm talking even like there wasn't
a peep in the room here we'll study I
was a good story just didn't pay
attention sometimes listen man those two
you uh you know you uh you're wearing a
crystally a pair of shirt you think he
says it's an eagle it's a parrot -
[ __ ] parrot yeah they all got an
eagle well in his mind it was an eagle
you know that right yeah I know Wow
looks like a parrot bro next time you
know was a play off of a Gila River
shirt with the playoffs Drake's owl
shirt and I'll have people like damn dog
how'd you get in line early let's get
that Drake certainly you're awfully not
that big Drake fan I send pictures of
birds to Christa Leah I just send up
like a bird yeah he looks like I owe you
did a man burn shaven yeah in Toronto
yeah I told don't ever let me catch
clean shaven LA
how's that how's the movie role has this
how is it being an Albanian sex trader
this executive uh it's exactly what he
looks like
dude yes sir when we got back from
Oklahoma gotten uber from the airport
yeah jump in this guy is way too much
cologne our meeting guy and [ __ ] what
about Joe Bob you'd never go to yeah but
he's going whoa but uh my mouth he's a
whoa bum up oh no dude and he's driving
through traffic yeah it's like taking I
mean I very much like dude they're macho
not my guys didn't give all [ __ ] hairy
arms oh yeah dress well there's so much
cologne I was like oh I feel sick he's
doing you you you stopping start like oh
my god and I go dude is there ain't you
I'm in no race to get the body into
Daniels swear live man swear driving
he's celebrating on Sunday yeah just
celebrating with music so sick time so
interesting I don't know people like
that I don't like when I get in car and
they have air freshener air freshener
kills me I don't know why if it's real
strong yeah I can't stand it and then
there are some people that just have no
they like so what if I'm playing music I
don't want to hear it like I don't want
to put my music on your ears I'm some
people could give a [ __ ] they could well
I did a I did a little SBU that show as
for you with the ice ice tea iced tea
and iced tea comes in it's 5:30 in the
morning it's me Chris Maloney and code
you know actors there these guys are
regulars and Chris Maloney basically I'm
sorry ice-t who's great guy really nice
man but he just puts on his new album at
level 9 at 5:30
hey Winnie Jana said I swear to God like
a night you listen and nobody says I
said you know he said check it iced tea
and he goes and the song goes that two
kinds of [ __ ] in the world [ __ ] is
that while you win a [ __ ] or whatever
it was to you there's a cougar dude and
he couldn't be more [ __ ] macho could
not be more modern you three light
doesn't say can't say [ __ ] man how this
is great - that's right so loud I was
like babe here's anybody else I would've
been like white turn that music down
right [ __ ] in the hands all you when I
graduate for this [ __ ] just not over the
clouds with ice-t yeah he's cool he's
super cool though actually it's kind of
killing it I'd I've worked with him
twice uh he's always killed it he was a
ranger do you know that in the military
which I never in it was really yep he
was a ranger seen his girl there the
Holly Coco Loco dude I saw her 20 years
ago he's been with her forever
oh she was gorgeous he had a white girl
with a black girl body he had a pit bull
I know this only because the dog was in
the vet with me had a pit bull named
convict and it had skin cancer just like
the bad name for pecans I heard he has a
rough time you know I know
breast from Oklahoma man I can be happy
to be back in LA I'd be honest not that
I don't like Oklahoma we were actually
we were in Siloam siloam springs
arkansas is it so Omar Salaam so sellout
so Malika so long beautiful part of the
world it is nice yeah I feel at peace
there
the simple life and it's basically in
the middle of the country landlocked
there was a giant house where if it was
here in LA
six seven million dollars probably
forget it's so [ __ ] big and Brian
kills the drivers how much video house
is he'll [ __ ] down one 202 or fifty
thousand the way he said it was like
that I'm running at least two 200 by 200
maybe 250 thousand dollars oh well
what's wrong with it I was like I know
like in LA so much you can't look at a
frickin you can't look at a
tractor-trailer for that much not only
can't get a [ __ ] yeah what you know
what they're doing in Venice is they
take those huge containers that they
ship [ __ ] in you know those you know big
containers like that they put on and
they are hot they basically cut our
window in those and those are becoming
Peabody houses is yeah it's pretty well
pretty stupid yeah but listen so I'll
tell you what those uh I'm trying to
stick to Oklahoma here for a second the
coffee in Oklahoma at poor John's not
matter some of the best not mad at
Hollywood honest though went there last
year this is a nice little quaint place
and we could be you know could be right
off Dennis here some nice little shop go
back it's what two-story poor John's
we're all fancy about the footage 28
Springs they got a restaurant there I'll
put that foot up against anybody 28
Springs beautiful is that if there's a
lot of money there I found out
headquarters Tyson chicken headquarters
Walmart law headquarters we got some
real money not a big college I guess the
John Brown University John Brown's gonna
be Manasa a university but and also
those are in that town well John Brown
is no John Brown is that's not the
university who told now it's not got
that are behind of you but it still a
liberal arts university and usually when
you have a liberal arts university like
that you get a good coffee shop you get
like kind of I guess that's a real
country town man I'm a place it's time
yes good that does it downtown it sure
don't do them like that there's a
downtown that they shut down on Sundays
lose all three-peat everybody's Church
three people and a nothing everything's
closed yes yes you mister still still
your boat there who's I these are my 5/4
I wear these all the time now good nice
I'm so comfy and my wife was like I love
loafers I was like alright I'll wear
it's rarely she says that I love loafer
love like you like my loafers are
love the lady just dude I swear to God
my wife if she could watch grandpa porn
she would like she's into old dudes that
a real thing
yes it is and she wants me to be in
Kenya and the United Kingdom
are the places where granny porn is the
most popular but that's a whole
different story
she wants me to get old like if I die my
beard which I'm gonna she is like don't
die rate I want you gray weird and when
I were clad with your silver [ __ ] dude
if I yes if I wear glasses all you get a
book reading a dick side Maya Rudolph
you know from Saturday Night Live yeah
okay her her father is a guy who is um
he was it in record executive I'm
forgetting his name but son he is I saw
him I saw Maya and I saw and she's she's
she came out and hey how you do I know
her a little bit and her father came out
and her father is a handsome 65 year old
maybe seven year old handsome you could
see he was and my wife lit up like a
Christmas tree and I'm not getting that
rating like a Christmas tree
like the older man she loves him she was
thinking of bring up Jim bring us up the
billboards Awards were last night
sheer performed she's 71 she's 71 71
bring her up a semi one now she's a
force in nature wait you will have you
so she won an Oscar
tami award billboard she's literally
done done it all I don't know she won
all that [ __ ] and you know what people
don't realize she did a lot but get that
she's 71 are you talking about 71
that'll last leg no it's not I swear to
God how do i watch all that often look
at the look at those test tips leave
those perky grin body dude it's 71 what
is she doing and she was wasn't bad at
all when she came out you know do you
believe in love about the look what that
kind of sucks is all robotic but then
she did her original if I could turn
back time that [ __ ] was epic I mean oh
that's so impressive look at her that's
her that's a lot of plastic surgery but
her doctors the best there is
I came I look at what it is look at her
at 71 that's ridiculous
you know what universe you know were her
and Sonny had a daughter together yes
and then she's transitioned to a may s
they showed him in the crowd
my book has a beard better beard than me
let me see jaws right Chad Chaz Bono
that's my mother hey but-but-but beard
it up better beard than you like a model
Wow look at that that's so wild are the
awards yeah - dude yeah jazz billboard
award man just get some hormones in you
I don't know I feel like that's another
lab that's impressive is what it is
science look science is going to be able
to do some crabbing look at what it's
already doing that's impressive
I'll crazy that though she performs his
pasties dude and I swing Dione sung her
famous Titanic song it's emotional man
udemy shut she shut that [ __ ] down -
maybe I can sing whoo she can sing
was it great song of old as Quincy Jones
said she can sang look at her and look
at that beard son that's why that's a
death that's a straight-up horner woman
now let straight up dude obviously
that's that's fascinating I mean he
looks better as a guy anyway right there
do it before and after there was a
documentary on The Oprah Winfrey uh
channel whatever that's called and I
didn't see it but I was dying to I
missed the Nate and then it does not a
bad-looking guy well I don't know yeah
well why sure looks I mean he's got did
Chaz has got I mean or what's his name
now Chaz Chaz probably likes his food
some people have asked wrestle with
their weight you know I mean look at
that though that's nuts man not a
bad-looking dude no not at all that's
impressive
I wonder what that's like as a parent
you know cuz son didn't Sonny died in
Aspen
yeah hit a tree man that's a bond of
crazy people died like that skiing more
than you would imagine like like if you
look at it it's crazy
[ __ ] yeah they run in a tree on other
people it's just crazy you know
obviously no one expects and there's
nothing wrong with I'm not showing it
anything like that but I'm Sonny and
Cher
you know if you like a kid bring a
picture one
look at that picture of the three of
them the black and white ones yeah you
know they give you drugs to enlarge your
clitoris into a familia they give you a
lot of things I'm just saying it may
create like leave a little girl how cute
is she yeah and if you tell the parents
hey that's pre-made dude oh yeah 20
years yeah you know it's just tough that
not again not that anything vile it's
just tough to take down damn that's a
girl I don't know is it either way I
mean before I like I know you mean
Justin okay okay okay I'm going to be
very quiet
one thing I will say I myself am I'm
gonna take a lot of space on his better
mind yes not bad and look at your guide
piece damn cheese NAT sound girl was
just a friend oh no because I know you
don't know she I don't know but I'm just
going to say it here's the thing hate
loan you know we noticed in in Arkansas
and god bless a lot of hot girls with
very heavy dudes am I wrong not in
Geneva yeah it was kind of an
interesting time peace girlie because
out of a guy and the guy was like had
been missing zero meals
nothing anything's wrong with announcer
like des like guys guys yeah they're men
that's what it is
yeah together we met they got themselves
a [ __ ] up man man and we met some some
full-blooded Cherokee and those dudes
were some big men how about big with
those guys beginning to brothers big old
Native Americans I think is a proper
term gave you an eagle feather give me
an eagle feather which is an honor we
have in the studio yep and but those
guys were every bit
they were I'll put him up against any
Samoan on the planet they release big
boys we're trying to figure out my
brother brought this up because I was a
gamer you full-blooded Indian we don't
know if Indians bad to call if it's bad
to call minions or Native Americans I
think it's better to copy narcs I would
err on the side of caution because
Indian was I've you know I won't do is
listen to white guys who don't know so
when those if those Indians tell me I
will never make the mistake in when
people who might have heads right it
might depend it depends on but if
anything goes hey it's all good man you
know I'm saying everybody there there
are plenty of sports teams like the
Cleveland Indians aren't they [ __ ]
right you know I mean Washington [ __ ]
yeah I mean they've had some issues they
had some issues they've been trying to
change up for
I've been watching like now we like to
read do like I got your racism yeah why
not change the lip skin Friday
yes Laurie is signing up for debate like
they get like they'll have protests
Indians will go out there and they've
make you look like you want all will go
out to the state yeah they'll protest
every year for training camp gain size
like a cool go Redskins yeah they never
change why see if you were to refer to
Asian people as yellow which will used
to be the common if you had a baseball
glove called the yellow skin so be weird
you think that would fly right or if we
had a basketball team called black skins
even I'd be an issue
all right well we had a football team
named white skins not an issue
yeah white skin but if you had a climate
again if you had a Cuban baseball team
called the brown skin mean issue yeah I
would imagine or you have an all Mexican
team called the wetbacks
give me an issue well that's gonna be an
issue so how do we just give the [ __ ]
the free pass
maybe we should started go fund me to
change the name well we would change it
so that's been going on for what should
we change - um - I had one Indian
reached out to me and we went back and
forth hated each other DMing arm
everybody goes when you call when you
call Indian savages it's [ __ ] up man
we're not stabbing home
you were you were savages and by savages
I don't mean I'm not trying to discredit
you guys or you know I'm not I'm not
referring to you guys as these the fans
you know let these monsters I'm saying
savages in the wave that you took over
other tribes and matter of habit is a
very very loaded word let me tell you
why historically Cano they told me yeah
but let me tell you because because it's
important no no bait nonsense Adam
Savage was a word used by white settlers
and and scalp hunters and Europeans for
black and for Native Americans when they
came into the country and they said
they're savages and and more importantly
the savages need to be educated and
turned toward our God and and their way
of life has to be Squad like get a good
on some but no that doesn't matter to us
2017 because those were two differently
nervous it's a little different meaning
though savage now is a term that a lot
of people use for an athlete who's
killing me sure so when L can't use it
for a Native Americans too
what I'm saying or for say say African
we can't claim the word savage you can't
say you can't use the word say I
wouldn't tell you that they're claiming
the word average I would say that the
word savage was imposed on them against
their will and they paid a very dear
price for it so that's why when you hear
a Native Americans say hey you just call
the savages that was always a trigger
word and was you still as trigger and
was used as a provocation this guy went
back and forth to a wild I said dude I
get it
I'll try not to refer to just any of
those savages yeah I like the word
savage personally
oh you can't assign from using so no I
like whatever happens when you go that
dude's out [ __ ] Savage like I like
that word it said to me it means a
different thing right so I don't mean
any harm in doing it yeah so if they're
not attack if there's an Indian in the
UFC or Native American we're [ __ ]
like all not your goddamn like as a
savage
I'm not going damn that guy's a savvy
right I'm going back in time when
they're demeaning you at the breath
right I'll look at the connotation on
you you know I hate politically correct
[ __ ] so I know you mean know me this guy
went back and forth like talking [ __ ]
chiller he got nasty and then he's like
dude here's why and sent me like this
little I think was a clip on YouTube I
watch them like dude I get it I get I
won't stop using words savage but I'll
make sure I just don't use it towards
Native American exactly he goes that's
fair and that's cool that I'm a good
race Savage yeah savages are cool you
know if you call me a savage if you see
me just snortin and a buck and snort not
me and feel like that guy's a savage in
bed savage in bed is it could that I was
if a woman calls you a savage he's a
savage for she want that you don't want
to hear your girl refer to another dude
like if your girl's like ah he was just
that he's a piece of dick but the thing
is he's such a savage in bed no you
don't want what Realty all night bears
some girls who just understand how guys
think he said I remember the time I said
he had his girlfriend there I swear to
God and he's not he's like you know a
regular guy and she was like I mean you
know it was all physical with us talking
about her boyfriend I was like my head I
was like what she goes yeah his dick was
like a circus act so you know my friend
was like oh my see break up with that
[ __ ] right
Oh No why did you say that though I know
hey hey I was like I have a teacher or
something about male psychology hating
so within would they victim to savage
iced tea black people have their word
Koreans have their words mixing have
their word white guys really don't like
if I walk by a group of whatever black
guys different ethnicity they go you
[ __ ] cracker not well that's because
who are having yeah but I think no
cracker refers to cracker is when the
black people would call white people who
would whip them crackers and the class
Howard comes yeah crash lock they crack
them with the web am super happy yeah no
racist said so racist
so they've told oh here comes the
cracker with whips of slaves so when you
call me a cracker it's like you're that
you're an oppressor but you know what a
lot of in locked rooms like a lot of
black guys then whatever my it was kind
of like eyes to knowing this like what's
up white boy I'm like can't I just be
Brendan yeah is there any way you can
just refer to me as like well well then
what's up human I think I was Jeff Ross
the comic who said I think it was him he
said I'm white so the difference they
mean everybody else that I can go back I
can get a time machine go back to the
seventeen hundred's it's still awesome
I can do anything doesn't matter what
time what time it is I can step out our
time see and be like ah 1600 whoa
I'm the guy who owns everything I'm a
white male whereas if you're black and
you go back if you get an anonymous tree
and you touch that dial and that Dow
hits the 50s even if you go back you
have seven you have 30 years got
something awesome yeah yeah not fun at
some problems you can't get that loan
brother sorry about that you know we
have a lot of Latinos there's really not
a horrible word for white guys mm-hmm
now which I'm surprised just white boy
gringo and haole redneck the redneck is
refers to a type of yes white person you
know yeah well you know no good just
part or white trash so that's like our
version like white trash is kind of like
yeah Dan crocheted Carla talks about
this all covered or wipe you you know I
would say poor I just say kind of like
uneducated like like the like the you
know I'm saying like white trash is
there white trash hillbilly like a lily
hillbilly white trash all that so
there's a book there two books my
hillbilly ology is white
I spoke very good books guys remember
you might be a redneck if I kill with my
hat oh yeah
holy [ __ ] II killed over there but
everything is like dang Carla talks
about how history is like is in Our
Lives all the time with United I've you
go up to a Chinese person and talk about
how the Mongols didn't do you know
didn't were that bad what was I needed
her to be like what the [ __ ] even though
this was something well he was talking
about any Chinese I was the Mongols well
at that so he was teaching this course
because him or a professor was talking
about like kind of looking at what the
Mongols did essentially when they when
they took over parts of China and killed
all those people and sort of he was
there was this idea that there was some
sort of development in the process and
that Chinese students were like hey go
[ __ ] yourself not a because do even not
even though it's six hundred years old
or whatever it was still raw I feel like
there's a little that enough is allowed
so well history history for certain
people like if you talk to our minions
about Turks good luck see what happens
and that happened in 1914 there was a
genocide but if you talk to them about
them 1914-1918 thing is a stretch but
anyway it's just interesting how we're
all a product of our history the more
you know that history the easier it is
to talk to people
you won't make big mistakes but you know
the big events the big genocides if
Sherman what nothing you need to like
what are you talking about nothing there
we'll talk what are you looking around
nothing miss you got to know that no I
know all right
what may seem like a mixed mental about
you like why you like the Turks no I'm
not a whole problem with it
I don't think too many people like with
those Chinese man up those Mongols are
full of [ __ ]
holding your smallish you've been always
been a Mongol apologist dude yeah me you
know that right cuz that's what the I
word I'm your mound of like the mongos
weren't that bad and I'm like Brendan
you better shut the [ __ ] up
yeah I don't know man Oh nowhere to go
with it or whatever sorry can I want to
talk about history no I'm good brother
I'm good man
you know what [ __ ] would you guys do
this weekend chin a Korean barbecue ooh
you and me both you do you want to what
again water yeah why do where did you go
what's that place called a mr. barbecue
and you bulletin area with an orderly on
it all static it's
outstanding but some white people Korean
barbecue yeah mostly actually a lot of
different Asian people I forgot how good
Korean food is god damn never had never
had a Korean barbecue we gotta go
you know you a spicy guy I don't think
you're hot you guys see you oh we've
liked it and what we do is these what ha
dude we gotta go it's right it's very
really close I have no desire oh man
you you gotta try it though you want
Jenny give you this amazing B go that
you just you fry right in front of you
and you take me to mr. and it's all keto
it's all like low carb and fat yesterday
just grill it just grill you just grill
in front it likes like Benihana style
yeah you get your order combos and
they'll give you just different cuts of
beef or pork you know and then you just
one plate at a time start grilling and
learn funny is have you had you human
yet Ethiopian food uh who would you go
with gin
I just hot buddy Joe Frank Marsh Lonnie
one damn now I want a Ethiopian food and
Korean food Ethiopian food Scots what
would you do our summer went to a
graduate college graduated oh yeah like
graduation parties or don't I know
father graduation parties right now huh
another graduation party I didn't do
[ __ ] for my graduation field can select
end of [ __ ] no I would of course you
graduate not do anything but that stuff
yeah
depends like I'm surely did it no my
parents were never celebrators not even
birthdays whatever is nothing going on
my bummer and Christmas was my mother
would rap [ __ ]' for the a today's yeah I
mean it's like that was just the way it
was we're not where my family is not
very sentimental I'll tell you what we
never said in my family I love you I
never said my mom or dad is her and they
never said to me cuz I was awkward
saying how where does I do not find it
uh hey hey let's catch a surprise it's a
little bit like like my family they
celebrate not but I've always wanted
always you know more like if I you like
I had a birthday party my friend my dude
I had elephants and I was surprised and
everyone was there like I damn it and I
got a car my 16th birthday I got a bike
seat when I'm saying so for my son I
wanna make sure he's here
by dagger-like it's for his birthday you
know what the [ __ ] is going on we had a
party at Disneyland
we like timing all the [ __ ] mascots
huge cage my mother's asleep
my wife will stop time for birthday
parties and I made him my dad we're in
venison it was my daughter's like fourth
birthday party right he's a
four-year-old well my life decided to
roll in the old animals she calls an
animal like sanctuary and I'm not my dad
was there my father comes running up and
goes hey there's a full-grown wolf in
your backyard right now and I deal with
you have got a hold on these guys it's
an amazing service but these guys roll
up in trucks and I was like how much
this cost me didn't cost me as much as I
thought they rolled out with a serval
it's like a cheetah
you know the serval is it's basically
all she is Mike small cheetah a
full-grown baboon a full-grown fabula
bad idea which was on which by the way
was you think a snake that had to be 24
feet long I love it all right
a wolf ate of the piece de resistance
was this giant [ __ ] wolf that jumped
up on the table and I'm telling you dude
this thing had it was a timber wolf
they're so big it is so big these things
can bring down an elk I was like you
have four year old world if I sang a
little back a little bit several other
monkey scorpion uh you know tarantula is
not suitable and then finally finally
the the baddest thing was it was a
[ __ ] African porcupine pull that up
for a second so we can see it it was a
full grunt so it's in the cage and you
just hear this
de Guiche [ __ ] illusion I was like
what's going on
pulls out this [ __ ] porcupine we had
to stay back they're giant they're giant
look he will lie in a way yeah hey
goddamn look at the day for little kid
yeah that thing was nuts so that's the
birthday parties we have pretty
interesting that's a big-ass porcupine
that really I like porcupines in yeah
they're cutie pies I was that Africa not
Australia
well they got different kinds of works
behind say got American
hey chin if I can set up a great white
diver you do with me in Australia we
might have one day off agree white diet
yes probably not you wouldn't do it out
freak out I'll freak out
well you're in a cage though but
remember we saw those cliffs were they
the shark gets in the cage did see that
did you see that Nate the trailer with
what's that trailer for 47 47 meters Oh
47 meters oh I love sharks
yeah I'll watch it yeah documentary
movie its movie ah I don't care about
that
it's pretty scary this is a documentary
scare me more it dude i watch
yeah it looks funny Mandy wait many
morning great whites yeah I'm out
really I'm out and he's a many more
great what my mouth anymore though who
is she I don't know she has you well
when sue year name what yeah yeah by I
love a good shark movie she's shallow
yeah lol dude leak lively yes that
scared us a dime piece love yen is the
most ridiculous ending of all times o
[Music]
ever course exchanger Siri please you
have to drive we at least commit some
chin to jump in the world you are
indicates welcome aboard everybody
remember faster you breathe
err test me once you're down you're not
gonna want to come back up
it can take your breath away oh my god
oh there's don't clean your feet stop oh
that the brake well now we're not going
Brian I'll raise you [ __ ] you don't want
to get you I go low low like that who
she like on the top though don't where
you figured out
[Music]
you miss your [ __ ] inside big shark
that search me meaning it's the movie
friend
[Music]
47 meters down
ah that's scaring that scared me
that looks pretty legit though yeah at
all speaking of movies dude I saw the
new aliens this possibly turned out
what's odd last night you saw last night
I did that movie is so [ __ ] anyways
yes my favorite so I love Prometheus so
if you guys are going to see I've been
seeing a yeah I'm one giving spoilers
but it goes so prometheus is the very
first one then this new alien and aliens
one aliens - aliens three that's the
order so make sure you watch Prometheus
1 to understand what the [ __ ] is going
on this new a way ok I'll let you be a
little a little confused yeah yeah it's
so good though y'all man great I'm a
hater
that [ __ ] was good it was good that
aliens Bala that ass yeah it's so fun
good responses Fassbender I'm getting to
seeing that longer great actor great
they're all great actor you know regular
dating a pride
how about Danny McBride I said you know
I loved Amy McBride he's I see from
eastbound and down I thought you'd be
like kool-aid not funny
no to marry girl very good is great I
was a great movie man that's what I've
seen a long time man I hate Hyperloop is
not people him that God's will see the
best and you'll see it I let you down
and it was good
mm-hmm I love me some aliens so I they
delivered yeah how that new mummy remake
[ __ ] you I did that how you put I didn't
replace Brendan Fraser about the time
was killing it love the guy made the
named Brendan famous for a while
it was Brendan Shanahan then Brendan
Fraser but uh I love the mummy one mommy
- he was brilliant never say they
rereleased it he had Tom Cruise in it
another mummys a chick hmm come on mix
it up bro it's weak in it yeah I don't
know I am chintzy - Tom Cruise - in a
mummy movie
what uh what see as you go to the one at
the Third Street Promenade
now here's the thing about the Third
Street Promenade in Santa Monica which
is not Dora ball for all you people
listening I don't know who's giving out
licenses for certain performers I don't
think I think by the FO my god is that
ruff is he's just a free-for-all because
yeah you can just get up there you guys
you got to get
sort of permit I had there is one woman
who I don't know what language in here
then did you start singing there before
we tried yes and they said you need a
permit
oh but you actually pull it off somebody
some of those some of those dudes you
get a guy who just has a terrible
speaker and a mic and he's on a piece of
cardboard and this guy was dressed
he was like from somewhere it's
somewhere in like the layman sorry
thought Adela and Friday
I like dude and his voice my voice
actually better right now than his was
and I'm like who the [ __ ] and then I go
a little bit further than this another
woman nobody's put any money in there
she's like I was like all right I mean
I'd rather be at the dentist right now
having my [ __ ] teeth drilled whoops
good Street yeah but it's what you
expect you say like in Lionel Richie
your biography is what I expect if
you're going to perform it like that
loudly on the street can you pass some
Priory abano just but also but can we
lock you know we get a little bit made a
lot of bad decisions its performance
search feel at Sunday night I don't have
that don't have it because they weren't
making any money and there's another
dude with a set of drums and he was
addressed in this I the drums didn't
work like the drums were like he found
pieces and I think you judge did you
this yeah or they're late night yeah it
was early at the b-team is how it is
Oman you go on a [ __ ] Saturday
afternoon yeah you get some talent yeah
okay cuz I people can't get what this
was B team [ __ ] this was like we just
was you don't search to that nine
o'clock eight nine when I put on this
you and I literally put a piece of wood
down and said Brian Brad I'm going to do
some tap dancing we would be we'd fit in
it would be fine and be like that's a
terrible America's Got Talent at nine
o'clock on this we make some hottie you
go down on Friday or it's like Saturday
when it's packed you seen some legit but
b-boy dancers there's some seniors there
there's this band and they were handing
out their albums like for sure just put
on iTunes man but they're handing out
CDs they were so good really you're
talking crowd okay yeah yeah no there's
some legit being a there for sure well
let's let's go ahead and I feel
I went surgery in last Dennis the
boardwalk
you're the best Barak it's more like
walking for class and [ __ ] weird stuff
now yeah all the move to 30 days gives
more money a guy in a speedo super
muscular on rollers rollerblades
juggling have you seen the guys Abbot
Kinney who's just he's in a speedo he
decent body tan it's [ __ ] blonde hair
surfer just holds a sign that was like
hey put money here I'm trying to make it
in Hollywood he just sits out in film
he's just in a speedo
he's obviously batshit crazy you're
gonna say bodied up four days a bum ba
ba ba - yeah definitely gonna be like
someone's side James yeah yes you just
there it's like give me money trying to
make in Hollywood there is literally
give me money Charlie there's a dude
where I play tennis down on the beach
and indeed there's a small Court where
you just hit the ball against the wall
and in that and in that court he spends
and I talked to the our pros who were
there who play he spends three to four
hours a day doing martial arts forms
like he does for most of them I don't
know he wears and I didn't look homeless
he's just kind of a stocky white guy and
he wears wraparound sunglasses and a
like a do-rag by waiting for sunday
clothes being the least of Furion he
does he does he does kind of bad if you
got bad Taekwondo forms and then I've
seen a good one and then today he was
squatting down as I was playing and I
could see him through the fence he was
going well suitable but most of all Ruth
isn't blue Lilith and I was like what
the [ __ ] Italy like her daddy was
leaking at fluent Russian but no I don't
think anybody was on the other end of
the phone school though he's crazy that
she could yeah when you're when you're
40-something and you're doing forms
before that I had that guy come up to me
I was running in Santa Monica and he
came with you I'm looking to get a
trained German Shepherd he came up to me
we go what's up man my dog I'm trying to
I didn't have told on the other day did
I God dude can I'm like I'm all set on
friends man yeah all set
give me a number and now and now I'm
like I don't I haven't ran all this I'm
worried I'm gonna run into him we're
gonna get you a good German Shepherd I
don't know if you're the guy for the job
I've had people reach out yeah yeah just
talk to my guy at least to get an idea
it's too serious for me I met him too
serious is in that you don't want a dog
that oh I don't want to check line no
too much so agenda yeah I've looked
around I thought some people people been
DM me some sweet like German shepherds
local stuff it's cool I'm just jealous I
want to be part of the process yeah I'll
give you my dog I like your dog she's so
cute she's cool but I really need
yeah um you know what I don't like you
know what I decided oh this is a little
off the topic but I don't like being
spellers you know what I'm saying you
know I'm talking about being spellers
you know guys spill the old beans we may
like a whole secret yeah you know guys
like that how about those guys who tell
their wives or girlfriends [ __ ]
everything it's my best friend oh hey
man why you think she's your best friend
you like if she would let you [ __ ] that
girl over yes my best friend let me do
that she's your best friend she let you
[ __ ] the hot girl on the road my best
I could
my buddy or my one time he came to see
me and it was like I was we were young
dudes and I was like I got this girl it
wants to bang I can't really see right
now there are friends who'd be like what
dude you don't wanna spend time with me
like [ __ ] off now made you think of it
because my friend told me my friend I
don't get too detailed but my friend was
like cause memory goes hey you know I
told such-and-such some sensitive [ __ ]
he goes and [ __ ] blabs it to his wife
now my his wife tells my wife he's and I
was in some DV I'm like hey you [ __ ]
beam Spiller ya attached to my go stop
being a [ __ ] bean speller goes what
type of actor don't say bean Spiller
you're the [ __ ] bean Spiller I said
well I'd say just don't be a [ __ ] huh
no I call it lean on your beans feller I
would have bean [ __ ] Lily it ain't it
yeah bean [ __ ] yeah I was funny
Dean so is like what he's three well I
like being Spiller cuz you don't build
the beans I get that so old-school so
what you have beans Spiller because
people don't know what it is at first
and you just keep hitting them with it
why are you being speller I feel like
most guys aren't like that though are
they social life you know you never know
bro you never know till school until
it's too [ __ ] late and and there are
guys that are simply best friends like
Mike my boy Fabrizio's best friends with
his wife the Fabrice is not telling to
do my I know there's nothing wrong being
best friends dude girl but that's like
guy talk guy talking into that's all it
is yeah that's right this stuff you
don't shoot a girl Emily oh my god my
boy Ryan [ __ ] a committee on the road
you believe that [ __ ] it's not that's
not for her area yeah ever that's on the
same tire to go right on this guy in a
particular goes right home and just get
that good good yeah guys like Wow can't
be my friend get some current events Jim
yeah what's current event it up alright
the first current event is a boxing
match over the weekend maybe controversy
on it Andre do like I really could have
bring it up my service and Oklahoma
sucks I heard about it show what's going
on here Jinzo and radar all fought whose
could tech we I think that's his name
Jose Oscar tech we and then he punched
him like two times after the Bell the
last time he punched him he got knocked
out yeah so who's quit Darrell's cousin
I think it is or uncle came over and
then shocked let's watch this well
here's the beginning of it so just of
this is where he socked him after the
belt others after the Bell God God can I
help I just a bell yeah like is he in
motion powerful Mario is in motion so
it's really close to me anything I heard
boxing is different
he did it before yeah I let's see the
before 170 Hardy and he's apologizing
yeah and he lost to a disqualification
act his uncle yo great left hook sir
horrible right hand yeah you're gonna
rest it's gonna be I'm go to jail after
that and why isn't that fat uh
dj khaled I will knock him out though no
knock he's professional boxer
I'm getting hit by civilian I was about
now I was better I got boxes and that
was a good that was a good left right
there his other punches were so terrible
I don't know what week as far as after
the belt did see my kills
I see before I [ __ ] his clothes man
and it got it's close let's play one
more time
I mean thought the more I watch that
little pretty well first of all again so
dead he had had gone back on saying I
need to see the first one he got worn
before right right he's obviously has an
issue death definitely dirty [ __ ] we got
one before that's some dirty [ __ ] and he
lose his right he gets disqualified off
I heard a guy gets the win yeah which is
how it should be yes and it amazed to be
in no contest
Wow and warrant yeah in MMA her team say
ah maybe it's a while here maybe they
here's a battle I'm gonna give him
answer the doubtless or heard a damn
what do you think of that though like I
mean it looked like he he swung ping and
he threw again with this yeah yeah
that's pure violence dirty okay yeah
just interesting you guys are talking
more about the late punch than the uncle
coming over and some hacking like that
that to me is a guy who has trouble
controlling his anger he was you know he
sometimes you know you're so angry and
so he that you're like I'll just take
whatever in that moment you're like [ __ ]
it
I'll you know sue knows what the
technicals background so like he's why
so pissed that he [ __ ] his you know
but he was nephew up like that oh really
hit him I would say gay his boxing
experience it's a pretty good left hand
it was not a good left turned his body
into that and that guy's on the run now
well actually let it leave and not get
caught while he's not just outrun the
run and now the police are saying that
he could get a maximum of 25 years if he
gets hot it makes it wait like it he
applied got to be honest private we've
seen guys just before you put googly got
a slap on the wrist if you had either
yeah they're not you know the people can
kind of stand so she I don't know what
this is Marilyn he's probably not a very
good decision maker okay I don't think
that's fair to say it means a heated
moment that's his nephew just no I'm
saying run away running away afterwards
another bad decision
you know so I would say it is but he's
not you know also might have a record so
there's reason why he's run away again
again bad decision me I'm here right
there are a lot of reasons but
Washington DC yeah
so I'm sorry for what my coach does I
mean visas coach if I have somebody
who'd hope you some boxing background
yeah I would imagine happy to me look
like a good left hook but I mean on his
other ones were so bad
god that's disappointing goof so there's
that oh yeah Briggs test positive where
Shannon breaks that five steroid no
championship fights off class I said
this to Rogan wait your boy yet [ __ ]
taught you know just wrote on one
podcast big fan of them increased
testosterone level yeah obviously you
ever seen Shannon Briggs have you seen
him at these days would you have forty
how old is he 40-something yeah it's
forty and here I'm like free your cell
phone whole nine there's an testosterone
was basically eight to one far exceeds
allowable threshold of four to one which
is pretty loosey-goosey for the one
ain't bad
what does that mean for one four to one
ratio testosterone level break sixty and
six the d3 code he's 45 Wow
I mean of course he's gonna you know be
doing some [ __ ] also is it that big a
deal like at forty five using some
subpoenas on PT and also 701 kind of not
that bad it's not like he's juiced to
the gills nothing taking some [ __ ] but
at 45 of course he's taking [ __ ] to look
like that I think y'all M do a stain
yeah I think it's 45 come on so I heard
that the whole four to one level thing
is they they put the threshold so high
to make it sure if you pass it then
you're absolutely cheating alright so at
forty one is actually so you know the
Olympics I want to say two to one or one
to what Olympics is does not [ __ ] around
let me smite be two to one it's so
[ __ ] crazy but yeah for the ones
pretty yeah pretty lean it because
there's some guys who have that high
testosterone good lord
now he's now you're super screwed at 45
you lose the title fight you've been
looking for that's positive right game
over really probably yeah
- ooh boxers even get like flagged for
testosterone the last one you see
another longer not a lot but I mean yeah
I think Vargas like years and years ago
to go Shane Mosley would you say that
would you say though that a lot of them
are yeah yeah any but any I'm not
knocking on boxing UFC boxing NFL NBA
MLB a lot of guys on peds it's a lot of
pressure sports or as part of it it's
not you know aisle
I don't shun Briggs at 45 like that was
going on easy most forty fighters look
like that you think shares all-natural
71 looking ok let's go here stone on
here and I said yeah and everyone
everyone knows the human body compares
him to know and you say well you know
he's a lead level athlete still 45 yeah
we love last like they each man was the
Hershel Walker
yeah as a heavy issues any sort of
statement or anything I mean he's pretty
shrouded he's jacked man yeah at least
be way bigger to the bomber but what do
you do and he's just said setting it
wasn't working one day one was he caught
was it like a recently on Saturday I
said to really on Saturday Sunday and
Trump signs 110 billion dollar arms deal
with Saudi Arabia
okay I'm champagnes powerful 47 downfall
is freedom or let's sucks man game over
what else you get you another boxing why
not I saw this crazy seven punch combo
did you guys see the Sun I saw the I
what is he goes nasties come above all I
thought it was fake I thought it was
like a movie thing yeah yeah
Oh watch the worked on this with your
boxing coach P lol buddy watch this it's
stupid watches
not even yet no you know oh my god the
movie living quickest hands in the West
wow that's impressive and I think the
body shots like oh no that's how great
is that
oh my lord that's a thing of beauty man
your science there yeah how great is
that
amazing I think the body shot heard him
in the little days to the head and just
like that tough last night now I know
I'm gonna do in West Fargo dude do that
I knew I mean he says hold on to your
coats on I have -7 punch combo guess who
sews a simple inch calmly it's hard to
pull off right I do now be hard to pull
off into anything so price and punch
combo could you did your sketch in it
was a great week in a box I missed all
of it Crawford fought home Boyd the
little guy for a fully made with fat
he's an absolute monster crazy he's so
good I think not getting the third round
yeah some Showtime he's full a with my
cottage a little Mike Tyson hi Daddy a
featherweight small small dude will
champion now he's the youngest world
champion does we have all right outside
of boxing there's a big game hunter who
was hunting elephants and he messed up
with a herd he walked into a herd
breeding so him and his team shot shot
at the elephants just to warn them
one elephant ran towards them grabbed
him with his trunk picked him up his
buddy picked up a gun and shot elephant
elephant fell down on top of the guy
killed him crushed
yeah it's a big big animal that's the
dude gonna get crushed yeah god damn
what a shitty way to go well imagine if
I'd died pretty quickly but damn also
died doing what he you know chose to do
but [ __ ] yes
or you got dragged to this and [ __ ]
that disguise gone away the mall is by
an elephant
he owns like a safari thing what time
should he know I hate white children by
the foot I have knowing why kill an
elephant
I don't know the conservation thing
behind it but it does seem like Amazon
they kill the older ones because the
[ __ ] up that Patel Vince [ __ ] a
little woman but I don't know about the
elephant's me neither
I'm sure I'd like to think so I'm able
to give them shut the elf in the goddamn
temple
how cool are elephants maybe I love
elephant situ and they have really
intricate family structures too you know
if one dies we go back and mourn the
loss
yep I mean they were defending their
herd we're not one this was yeah the
older the older ones teach the young
ones how to behave and so when poachers
kill off the older elephants like the
ones with the trunks I mean the tusks
the the is that it is that a dead
leopard thought early on that when they
kill off the older more mature ones the
younger male elephants like the
adolescents a teenager's better lack of
a better word they become they kind of
just destroy the fabric of the herd
because they become bullies they beat up
on everybody including the older cows
and it's crazy the whole structure falls
apart because the old Bulls teach them
how to behave and they set an example
Manson and then they do have amazing
memories they can remember really crazy
animals yeah it's a shame and it is what
an elephant is for this to add a little
storage for me it's kind of what you
sign up for right tigrin and also if
you're that would be saved when the best
others all-time punching on the middle
of a goddamn elephant crew and shoot a
gun yeah like what you think yeah else's
but it's like you doing I'm crazy
you don't know elephants doing elephant
[ __ ] and other ideas you know for act
like that's not surprised you always say
to that you know when you are and like
somebody who rides off into your entire
land or India and they take care of
their elephants right so the Indians the
MA hoots they'll wash them they feed
them they spend you know a lifetime with
them but typically what they'll say is
that you just never know on any given
day if you're going to die because some
there's then it's it's not that rare
elephants again they can be tamed not
domesticated and elephants just for
whatever reason
someday just go and this happen to like
sir
I don't want to do this anymore and I'm
going to kill you and here's the problem
when they kill you it's pretty gruesome
because what they'll do is they'll step
on you and I keep stepping on you and
then they'll start pulling your arms and
legs off with their trunk the first ones
probably ready do it though yeah after
that do what everyone yeah I mean you
work out initial step but whatever two
tons it is your mashed your mash it they
mash it into a butter yeah it ain't good
well they'll see that soon making man
butter out of you yeah well [ __ ] around
alright so there was a UFC retreat this
past weekend well judo blending the
Dutch pure [ __ ] show retreat it sounds
like yeah I heard a lot of different
things happen but this is the one that
is the biggest one in the headlines
cyborg apparently punched Angelo Magana
do you know who Angela McGann is I don't
she's like she's not a real popularity
fighter but she was on tough on one of
the seasons and she has a little thing
where she she asked people to call her
your majesty that's your thing to be
popular and then she dresses really
provocative okay I gotta get a good
picture
McGann enough we did this picture of
cyborg making fun of were making fun of
her her looks and cyber confronted her
at the retreat and they had words and
apparently cyborg there's video of it
soon the video I didn't see the video
you can people up video if you look at
video sour pungent bring up that
Angelina Meg magna McDonough yeah bring
her ass you all worked with it okay good
yeah gonna get big on let me see what's
going on here for we turn to us I'm
Hannah I'm hat oh my god oh no matter so
get all I'm not mad at her at all I'm
not mad at her at all Christ girl so I
got Mikey crazy pictures that heard of
thumb all right well I might get a hero
problem why artists gosh you do the USD
absolutely you're 0 but you win what
Jesus yeah hey bro keep like you see I'm
arrow right there bro just keep going
like slidin let me just see what's up
bro
is that her inability to talk but this
is the yellow up there you gotta keep
going bro very happy with our own I
around others are I mean on her it's not
no not the left that's her
though that UFC making the UFC Reebok
can make anyone look like [ __ ]
I'm not matter ready though the video
the Beck Rawlings the other fighter DLC
fighter she said that she has a video of
it and then she's asking TMZ to buy it
yeah she needs my girl Emily um but if
there's video someone tweet its so
incentive to me on this game if you are
go up cyborg punching boot yeah there
you go did see video mergers serious
outdoors dude and then hit then she
busts right in the face okay
he's a Jedi bust his lip cyber will beat
her up
who's - oh my god who lifts the head
right another fight oh my god stop kid
don't look [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you god I
don't know what I was if there's gonna
be any repercussions all iboard she's
well my god I was saying that she's
gonna go after she's pressure arguing
her she's gonna go to jail
come on we gonna I mean it's kind of you
know uh listen Mikado's a dime piece I'm
not mad at her looks at all but how you
gonna talk to shitpost all that you're
your fighter you talk all this [ __ ] then
he come face-to-face you get you know
she didn't break your jaw you eat a
busted lip then you press charges
that's a [ __ ] when I'm with your brand
and you also lose all credibility in MMA
I'm waiting everyone to like you're a
[ __ ] if you want to lose every fan you
have press charges against another
fighter for talking [ __ ] then impose
fire and put them spirit of failure with
you and backs it up your [ __ ] I can act
like you put your post that mean
strategy guide it down now you can't
back imagine if Jon Jones soup DC cuz he
hit him in the face with a water bottle
what would that do to DC I agree
game over careers over Sony's get
magnesium like listen I get you upset if
you actually go through this and sue
cyborg you're [ __ ]
yeah bad also the UFC doesn't want that
your manager doesn't want that it's also
really expect also mean-spirited
say how about that it's also shitty it's
like you you so you post that that kind
of nasty picture of her for no reason
just because of the way she looks which
is a shitty thing to do in my opinion
anyway okay you're good-looking and
you're gonna make fun of somebody who's
you know who is not as good-looking as
you are but but also in the you're in
the business of the fight right
Angela Meg magna I've never heard of her
I'm so balls deep and everything I've
never heard of her
Angela magnet couldn't McGary
[ __ ] I don't know her [ __ ] name
couldn't carry cyborg shoes to hockey on
when you we talk about careers and
acting skill so if this is your way to
get attention
god damn you're going the wrong way girl
your best bet would have been punch her
right back in the face and create some
sort of dilemma there but not go silent
do the [ __ ] move in sewer let
professional fighters what are you doing
yep
agreed yeah answer the Magana rethink
your realtor John Jones a DC thing makes
it a little more I open e how bad it
would look if you think think think if
Nate Diaz sued conifers on that monster
I think people like oh my god I said oh
you're gangster bro yeah yeah sorry
ma'am soon I think you get more money
oh my god I'm gonna have to give you
back this 209 shirt and I can't you know
you're gonna ruin your career
terrible terrible move but I guess
people are talking about it
yeah what else you know brother that's a
bummer this thing is everywhere I'm
guessing you guys have seen this already
I haven't seen this you haven't seen it
no look I'll just play it for you then
see like see line drags girl - Stephen
sound boy this is a bull seat there's a
bull see line I get it 1,200 pounds to
the other business trip teeth yeah it's
a male and they're hungry and they're
territorial alright
[Music]
okay it is a wild sea liner now they let
this child they look like they're from
another country cuz that guy's fine
I like that god I've never seen anything
like that before a sea lion what's weird
is when I was a kid I was in Mexico
about to jump in the water and there's
like two big sea lions my dad I went to
running is no no no no no some our dad
and my dad's like those sea lions I know
you see like shark tonight
I've always been super into animals like
any sea you know I in books and on TV
like sea lions just get destroyed by
sharks those things will [ __ ] I remember
sighs my dad because a lot those things
will [ __ ] a human ah that's right and
they have so I grabbed sea urchin
something so so when you swim so people
have been known to swim with sea lions
like the females and if a bull is an
area it's it's been down the Bulls will
get territorial we're seeing this team I
like tusks yeah those I mean it's LA if
they're gnarly man yeah sea lions are no
joke now I've been scared so a 1200
pound animal which people don't realize
it but also evolved hundred pounds it's
the line of the sea
Alliance ooh now leprosy over leopard
seals are the apex predator but still
it's called a sea lion for a reason yeah
well it's anything with the name line in
it I don't get in huge I thought you see
basically a dog with no legs but bigger
yeah way bucking timber wolves on the
scene yeah yeah they're big they're big
boys sea lion yeah
lion is key word dude just don't [ __ ]
around
sea horse will difference a tiny little
thing I thought to see how it's me to
how Flicka sea with me too but we're not
afraid to see where it's already lying
different me with my something line
that's not lion fish don't go near it
why fish also scorpions yeah scorpion oh
yeah now you get you to your lionfish
it's gonna hit you in them quills it's
kind of poisonous oh yeah then somehow
streamline that won't kill you so
lion Lions those those are not nice it's
on a delay line tie my landline
my line we got we're dry line rip your
face off try kill you wet line see live
wet lines no fun there another lion
now you're right fish line live fish
lion fish anything with the name line in
it you better like one great lines
yay line hey hi dry line sea lion lion
fish there any airlines now no name
alive
flying line seahorse kind of ruins it
yeah does the sea horse sea lion you
know see yep
yeah sea snakes cool very poison hi god
I'm really in the world up for the dance
make one drop both of time if there's
sea in front of it I just [ __ ] see
what's ruined this whole concept if
they're seeing from it stick you later
well there's one like the venom in one
sea snake kill Kyle zoom in like
something like 150 dudes now bring that
up it something crazy
thousand thousand it let's party one
drop thousand I don't know if it's that
I don't have as a care you talk to the
players
it's a lot ok you go but it's slot slot
most poisonous one is the beat sea snake
three drops of venom can kill about
eight people now let's redraw just
others do they have short fangs and they
are unable to bite through the divers to
very easily they're not likely to bite
me right hey sea cucumber whine clear
you know when they pull up bring this
out when they pull up fish like a bunch
of fish a lot of times there's shitload
of sea snakes in the Nets check this out
and they got to get rid of them and
they're very and they're not small
they're not small they're rather large
nothing could give me is huge yeah
[ __ ] around with sea snakes dude please
don't [ __ ] around I mean three drops
kill they men then it's good steaks out
of the house until that coral to like we
were in Tahiti in that coral man when
you brush up against that coral enjoy
that some of that poison coral will
really mess you up
that's a big [ __ ] seasoning look
they're big yep I mean sweet talks fun
videos now there was I saw a really good
one damn it oh well whatever
yeah I don't think oh my god
on sea station a [ __ ] bet ROM man you
see that video by the kid oh do Brian
that helps to bring straight
there it is Oh oh this is only like six
months
oh [ __ ] yeah this is not on this guy's
voice is super entertaining oh god don't
die look at that steak you the basket
dudes about the pre-operational - those
are a lot of [ __ ] snakes probably how
big it is but they're super poisonous
you got your fish and you got a deep
snake your fish catch yellow
you got a deist naked bro and they're on
your boat
usually it's dangerous it's super
dangerous
yeah videos in Bible yeah I don't want
any snake in my fish is what I'm trying
to say bro why can't you respect that I
get him in what I'm seein all right
let's see this one a woman pointed a gun
battle Tony Age boy who was having sex
with her neighbor's daughter are you
bring a dog okay so we're going to
charge for pointing gun a teen allegedly
raping dog now here's the thing paying
Allah Allah I love it says thought she
was doing the right thing I got out my
gun I got my gun on my safe one in my
back door I told him get on the [ __ ]
ground pointed the gun
hey captain save a lie and lie
face-first life I live lie on your back
so you don't hurt break your dick this
is the second time apparently that this
kid did this that's why the cops told
her like to me how to catch him in the
act
it's done don't prosecute I got
videotape it and wonderful cop said you
know where's gun [ __ ] dogs I bet that
dogs like [ __ ] [ __ ] block and at
least problem is that dad watching your
old kid yeah I guess that dog is
technically property even though it is
bestiality you can't point a gun that
there is but I'm the house like what in
the world he looks like a guy who [ __ ]
law team yeah
at 14 if you [ __ ] the dog okay now now
here's my question
Brennan you're hiring a dude he's very
highly
skilled he's 25 you put two and two
together and you go when you were 14
seem to remember story about you [ __ ]
having a habitual dog [ __ ] issue I
can't work with you know hey that's it
is that it not even at 25 none it's been
it's been 11 years doesn't matter that's
what you do but if you're into that call
event hall I follow his my father is
something wrong it's not like he gets
over [ __ ] dog have your [ __ ] dogs
at 14 who knows what that leads to then
next thing you know your hind mr. hands
and then mr. formerly known as mr. hands
retired finds a kid he goes in a horse
stable that horse rips through his guts
[ __ ] first and now he's associated well
but getting [ __ ] and [ __ ] so when
he sees a dog he goes of that dog looks
like that like I can't match I see
darling look at that furry little kid he
mind if I pay your dog and you might the
thought bubble over my head is when I
was done well if he's like not look to
that I was like a motherless thing on a
muslin and wheelbarrow [ __ ] it's weird
huh this was that dog wearing a muzzle
you better wear a mother dog was it do
we know I think I'll spin a right guard
until they don't see each other Douglas
no wait was he sodomizing the dog a
rabies rate was raping a female dog
that's Tufts is she in trouble she she
is in trouble for pointing the gun at
him it's aggravated assault and that's
not the kid either yeah you don't show
the kids face cuz maybe he'll get over
it
but your son maybe it's just one of
those weird phases yeah that's your son
you gotta have a real oh my god my kids
are [ __ ] dogs like he's losing the
world can you not find a girl Oh what
are you doing yeah what the [ __ ] are you
doing why don't you use your handy it's
important like a goddamn normal kid he
had an iPad with him so he had he left
his iPad and his phone and then he
booked it with his [ __ ] so he's watching
porn mustard then why pretending that
dog was a nice sweet young girl
I still interesting to me yeah he was
just like you know I'm strikeout the
girls are you an idea I'm gonna [ __ ]
that dog but watch porn my buddy is a
cop in San Francisco and caught a
gentleman in his car [ __ ] a chicken
the thing he said well he was um and he
was married and it was all weird and the
guy was begging enough
like I have to call you in he felt bad
about it he's on the area t7 you find
women it is not have come sure than when
I say it's not uncommon but there have
been not okay long bitumen plank is
where women get [ __ ] by their dog I'll
be like that's more of a challenge a dog
will not go to mount you and put his
wiener in maybe 100 percent a 100
percent they had a lot goes in there's a
lot of moving pieces in that to Malik
not only that would be the Chilean army
under Pinochet use that to torture their
political prisoners women they would do
that and have a dog come in a big dog so
know it's it's it's done it's done and
all the cells right I'll tell you
something else really way to watch
history but it's trying to throw it on
it yeah it won't be with a cop relax
well tell you that I'll be reelected
though you dogs just [ __ ] every girl
in my head when you see the little
addition to her dog
I would say less than 1% population I
would I would agree I would agree that's
very rare but my friend told me that her
roommate would put peanut butter on her
CUDA JJ and let her Rottweiler naked all
mm-hmm and she did it on the regular
feel suit well that doesn't see us as
problems
that's Wade [ __ ] well probably feels
real good with nasty cats or a dog dude
why are you such a Puritan today man
weird huh oh now you gotta get all weird
huh I'm letting dog with it it's ER da
it's the dog's mouth is cleaner demands
that's what they sell if I agree with
that
I'm just saying what I'm saying time
again you can we plan a man to do that
maybe she couldn't
maybe she's super attached to her dog
and I'd [ __ ] Rottweilers got it - all
right what else yeah uh what if he grabs
his ears when she climaxes
look a trendy restaurant in Philadelphia
looks their customers pay whatever they
want and I'm not even free if they want
good idea well there's a guy who does
that with yoga in Santa Monica I think
it was Bryan Kest back in the
a and he made a fortune because it was
donation only right so people would you
know people have money depends on where
you are well you're in a wealthy area
people spend some money it's for you
know people that are poor and they can't
have like a nice three-course oh yeah so
this restaurant is letting them have the
option of of having a real college I
scare I like that very much
and pay dollar or less located a storage
business district of West Philadelphia
born and raised
the nonprofit welcomes everyone because
whether he can take it to him I live to
Abby's to get in there though I would
imagine 40 pack I would imagine I
wouldn't like rich people go there just
to give them a lot of money just to feel
good I was younger right must check and
not eat there yeah if you feel like I
don't want to [ __ ] you I really just
give you the money right and what I
would get the food is looks good looks
pretty good clean what kind of food is
it I think everything but it's a
three-course meal Saturdays for three to
eight but the other thing is so if it's
for poor people and there's these
whatever for five course meals how many
people are they really helping in
through their like you know in that four
hour window how many people get fed like
there's more efficient way to do this I
like it though no it's cool concept but
how many people are really feeding that
four hour window
right the restaurants food budget is
tight it's always it's yeah yes that's a
few weeks and will relies heavily on
food donations from supermarkets
bakeries churches they served homeless
people struggling moms students saddled
with debt okay good for you
it's kind of cool yeah we'll sketch in I
think that's it
all right man all right that's cool you
drop the notes like I'm now going to do
the one that I talked about in Arkansas
just really quickly cuz we'll holies a
little bit well call my Arkansas we had
a great time thanks for everybody coming
out sold out fantastic uh and there's an
article where Lena Dunham who is the
star and creator of girls on HBO good
show that's just a cute I wanted it I
don't know
I wanted to hate on it but actually
watched it not thought it was really
good but I don't like her politics
she's so progressively liberal it's
ridiculous she's just such a Marxist and
I guess Overland where she went to
school they got mad the students held us
sort of a protest because they were
serving bond me and sushi in the cafe
and the kids were like that's cultural
appropriation it's not acceptable for
white people to eat that food because
we're just taking over their culture
this is how craziest politically correct
[ __ ] goes on in our campuses it's
such [ __ ] and Lena Dunham was like
right on and she was supportive of it
and the problem with that is that there
this country is strong because precisely
because we borrow from cultures
precisely because we are one big melting
pot of cultures let's take a burrito a
burrito has rice in it rice comes from
China let's take the idea of meat and
rice I came from Spain the idea that
Tomatoes well where the tomatoes come
they come from the Aztecs from South
America where does chocolate come from
South America but why did the Swiss
learn how to turn it into something
called hot chocolate the whole point of
this country is that we borrow the best
that that that is offered from different
cultures and we discard what we don't
want America is the best that all these
cultures have to offer when you go to
this country when you're Syrian and you
come here and you bring Syrian food here
it's some of the best in the world
that's the whole point so cultural
appropriation you dummies is what makes
our country strong and what we should be
doing so stop with this stuff this
politically correct [ __ ] gets like it
becomes a snake eating its own tail and
I want to just also say too to mention
what Jordan Peterson said on Joe Rogan
podcast if you're 17 18 19 20 you don't
know enough about the world to be trying
to change it this way worry about
yourself you're a young person keep your
own room clean worry about yourself you
have enough to get yourself in order
before you start trying to change the
economy try to change the way we think
and especially try to change the way we
eat okay
it's unamerican and pick up a history
book and take a look at how a cultural
appropriation makes you're like wait
and better starting with pizza Tomatoes
don't belong to Italy they belong to
South Africa South America for example
so that is my that is my rant boo boo
boom thank you for listening to joy
pizza enjoy pizza and burritos and bond
me bond me is in French baguette on it
that's from France that would fries I go
they don't have french fries in France
you know that I know how about my dad's
in Spain to to Tesco's I've been taking
pictures non-stop fun kid pansy or Wyatt
exercise a fine kid shirt on today know
that it see I'm sure he's done post it
well yeah they go oh you're fired kids
anyways I'm Brendan daddy get that [ __ ]
out here I take pictures with it's so
cool I think we posted one we've got a
few of them Papa shop just love in Spain
I feel like he's gonna move there never
come back you know wow I want to go
there I want to go to Barcelona
Barcelona let's really that my sight
scene yeah the stepmom Italy coffee it's
just a Starbucks every weather judgment
yeah you just kind of disappointed start
with you I said you know it can't be the
nice fresh cup of Starbucks though yeah
it's good good coffee great taco
well Brennan that's another podcast for
us that's it man um my next gig I don't
know where mine my next gig is buddy I
think it's going to be in Montreal with
you that's the way the way it is wait
till now if that table yeah
Tuesday night tomorrow night it will
when you guys was this Tuesday night you
and I at the Comedy Store we are yeah
we're doing Adam Murray spot is a show
forgot about that
I know all right come see us Tuesday
night Tommy store tomorrow night Brian
Ken and I will be there and then man
Australia all shows are almost sold out
Brisbane Melbourne Melbourne Melbourne
Overland Sydney and then I'm in New York
City on June 22nd Gotham comedy club and
then I'll be in the audience yes sir and
then July 28th I'm in Long Beach Laugh
Factory the day before the huge you see
an eye on card bringing that [ __ ] down
slaying some jokes that's at Long Beach
laughs after all tickets for Australia
New Zealand New York Long Beach t fat
kake.com we have some
hot as fire firing the kid tanks and
summer tees dropping in the next few
weeks where do you see these be a J sob
saved me some mediums are all freaked
out boom this is a finally kid we're out